[Musique]
bonjour à tous c'est denis brogniart je
voulais vous parler d'octobre rose ce
mois d'octobre consacré à la
sensibilisation sur le cancer du sein le
cancer du sein c'est le plus fréquent et
surtout le plus meurtrier chez la femme
alors pour améliorer le dépistage pour
faire progresser la recherche
on a besoin de vos dons on a besoin de
votre générosité
il faut être généreux pour protéger les
femmes que nous aimons pour cela c'est
très simple vous pouvez donner en allant
sur le site octobre rose point fondation
qui ré arc point org merci infiniment
pour votre générosité
cette fois
[Musique]
non
nous sommes
devant
[Rires]
[Musique]